[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABUZAR MANAGER: Today
what we're going to share
with you is not groundbreaking.
I can assure you that
a lot of this stuff
is stuff that you've
probably heard.
But as the saying goes,
it's not the mountains
that we stumble on.
It's the pebbles.
So if we cross the pebble,
each pebble by pebble,
soon we would have
crossed the mountain.
So today, we're here
to share with you
how we've crossed one
of our biggest mountains
over the last 2 and
1/2 years, and what
it has taken us to get there.
Sharing with you our vision, our
strategy, our building blocks,
and the journey
that we've covered
over the last few years.
So just to walk you
through very quickly,
we will share with
you the structure
that we've put in
place, our focus
areas, and our core objectives.
The vision that has allowed
us to deliver to our strategy
help us materialized
what we were to deliver.
And more importantly,
how we build
our structure and our wealth.
Our wealth in terms
of our resources.
Our people, our teams,
and more importantly,
our tools of trade.
We want to cover the journey.
The way this program started
off in 2016, and the way we've
journey through
2017 and to date.
Our building blocks
around our architecture,
our core focus, our roadmap.
The way we've
brought our service
management and automation,
our operations,
together to be able to
make this a success.
And finally, we
want to close with,
what were the challenges and
some of the food for thought
and recommendations that we
would like to leave with you.
When we started this journey,
it was important for us
to be able to have
a clear vision,
to be able to have a vision
that would help us build
a strategy that would
allow us to make
the leap from our legacy data
centers into public cloud.
Our focus areas
were around having
a very clear, and stable,
and optimized presence
in the public and
the private cloud.
That is where we were going to
live for the rest of our lives.
And we wanted to make
sure that we were
going to build that strongly.
We wanted to be able to
use our learnings from what
we were doing at the
legacy data centers
to be able to get better
savings through optimizations.
We wanted to provide
agility to our business.
simplicity to our business.
And most importantly,
enablement.
Enablement of technology,
solutions, and services.
And this is where we had to
carve out what our two core
strategies were going to be.
One of the strategies
for Schlumberger,
an organization that has
been, for over 100 years,
with 100,000 plus employees
over 85 countries,
was to be able to live
in the public cloud.
So we had to move all
our legacy data centers
to the public private cloud
in a multi-cloud environment.
The second strategy was to
be able to not only move
to public cloud, but also
be able to bring the managed
services in-house and be able
to understand how we do that
better, and be able to optimize
our performance of operating
our applications
in public cloud.
This journey over
2018 was focusing
around our digital enablement,
our savings and optimizations,
and most importantly, our
operational enablement.
One of the important
areas for us
was to be able to provide
our business the ability,
the simplicity, and the agility
to be able to optimize the oil
and gas business
in the tough times
that we've had over
the last few years.
As we journeyed along,
it was important for us
to not only focus on our
objectives in our core areas,
but it was also
important that we
look at how we structure
our core delivery areas.
It was important
for us as a program
to build the life
of the program.
But also what the core
focus areas and the delivery
areas were going to be.
And when I say that it
was imperative for us
as an organization to focus on
how we were going to structure
our architecture, our
service, and automation,
our delivery pillars, and most
importantly, our operations.
When the journey started, it
was more around how you've
been given a block of land.
This is the analogy
that's been there
from the time we
started the program.
You've been given
a block of land
and now you're expected to
actually move your furniture.
That's what you're doing.
But before you can
move your furniture,
it is important for
you to have a house.
And for you to have a house,
it's important for you
to have the architecture on what
you're going to be building it.
Your utilities, all your
suppliers, and so it
was a journey that we
had to sort of structure,
plan, and put the foundation
blocks to be able to get
to where we are today.
In 2019, what we are
going to be focusing on
is taking that journey
to the next step.
So I'll take a step back.
Over 2016, over
2017, our focus areas
have been on, how do
we put a methodology--
you've probably heard a lot
about the lift and shift.
You've heard about the rebuild,
re-architecture, remodeling, re
replatforming.
And all of that is very true.
And I assure you
that you probably
heard in sessions yesterday
that the core piece of being
able to migrate applications
from your legacy data centers
to public and private
cloud lies in your ability
to do a thorough assessment
of what your applications look
like, understanding
your technology,
and your legacy debt.
Understanding what
are your constraints
around your licensing abilities.
And most importantly,
making sure
that you have the right
partners in helping you
drive that journey.
In 2018, we successfully closed
one of our core data centers.
And we migrated 400
plus applications
to public and private cloud.
This, for anyone who's
embarked on the journey,
will realize that, over the
two years, achieving this
has been a cornerstone for us.
In 2019, now that we have
a presence and our footing
in public cloud,
our focus is now
on how we start to optimize,
automate, and start to exploit
the native offerings in cloud.
This is a journey roadmap
that's been a one slide that
helps us talk about what
that journey has been
and how we've moved
from cradle to grave
on the overall project.
What it shows you is that, if
you look at the big blue bar,
that's basically our
foundation, our roadmap.
That's our journey.
Everything you see on
top of the blue bar
is the fruits of our migrations.
That's basically
everything that is tangible
that has allowed us to
complete our pilots,
move into our discovery
phase, exit our data centers.
But at the same time, start
a modernization journey.
But none of the things that
you see above the blue line
would have been possible
if the roots, which
you see below the
blue line, which
is where our partner in Google,
our partner in our multi
cloud strategy, have actually
helped us build those footings.
So as we grow as an
enterprise in the public
and the private
cloud space, we grow
with our partners in Google,
and our partners in Azure,
and our private data centers.
So what you see
below is what we will
be talking a bit more in our
architecture discussions.
But what you see
above the line is
where we are focusing
more on the journey that
has happened, where we've sort
of structured over 2016 to 2017
and 2018.
And when the program
started in 2016,
the expectation was for us
to close down our legacy data
centers and have everything
in public and private cloud.
It was quite a stretch and
a challenging target for us
to achieve.
We had to put some structure.
We had to put some methodology.
We had to put some
robust teams in place
to help us journey
along this road.
One of those things
that has become
more and more evident
to us as we journey down
is, we needed to make sure
that we had the right partners
working with us, right?
And as we close
the session today,
we will share a
bit more about how
we've journeyed through
that and how we've made sure
that those partners have come
along with us and grown with us
as the public cloud
offerings have grown.
What you see on
this slide is also
telling you that, in 2016
when we started the journey,
our focus was on doing
a proof of concept,
doing a thorough assessment of
our applications to understand,
A, what was our application
landscape in terms
of simple, medium, and complex.
But also, what our
methodology for migration
was going to be around lift
and shift versus rebuild,
versus rearchitect, replatform.
This assessment
helped us carve out
what our 2017 roadmap
was going to look like,
where we journeyed along
and we took a major chunk
of our applications and
successfully got that across
to give us a validation
of our methodology.
In 2018, that became a
more well-oiled machine.
And that has helped us move
and journey along and shut down
one of our core data centers
that was one of our legacy data
centers, and holding about
400 plus applications
at that data center.
What has happened along
the way is, with the Google
and with our multi
cloud partners,
we've built the infrastructure
as a service offerings that
has helped us pave
the path not only
for footing in the
infrastructure as a service,
but subsequently now,
as we journey along
to modernize our applications,
make them more PaaS-ready,
and then subsequently
take them into containers.
Now, this could not
have been possible
without the support
of our architecture,
of our strategy
around how are we going to bring
service management in-house,
how are we going to
focus on structurizing
our operational support.
And this is some of
those things that we
want to talk about as we go
through the session today.
What I would like
to do now is, I
would like to invite
my colleague Sadia, who
is our lead architect
on the program,
to walk us through the core
focus areas for architecture.
SADIA MUKHTAR: I
don't think I need it.
I have one slide.
All right.
Can everybody hear me?
All right, great.
I don't have to speak out loud.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for the
introduction, Abuzar.
So I think if you guys were
here for a movie session,
I'm loving this environment.
This is the wrong session.
The session here that we
have is covering our journey,
and what we have done
within public cloud
and with our partners and
team within Schlumberger.
So before I even cover
our areas of focus,
one thing that I want to cover
is, from an organization's
perspective, what we have,
our guiding principles,
and support from our
architecture and governance
body, and a bias of my own team.
The principles that we
follow is cloud first.
If we are trying
to solve a business
problem or a technical problem
at hand, bias towards cloud
native technology
and solutions, that
is where we partner
with our cloud service
providers, with our TAM
teams, with the engineers that
work with us.
And then lastly,
it's very difficult
to predict where our six
months are going to be.
So what we do is, one of the
guiding principles that we
have, is any decision we take,
we have to reduce friction.
So when it comes to taking
decisions, making up your mind,
picking a technology, it is
a very quick pre-decision
when we go through
these three steps.
That being said,
what you see here
is, it looks like a
laundry list of things.
It's because it is a
We have them
categorized, so we can
focus our energies,
our work stream,
and our efforts in
these categories,
and we don't miss out on things.
I think one of the
things that our team
did is focus on security.
Security is one of the forefront
focuses of Schlumberger
and on my organization.
So identifying those aspects,
those areas, well, it's
very important for us.
I won't cover every aspect.
The ones that helped
us tremendously
was providing consistencies
in our security policy
and governance.
It meant rethinking
our approach.
Applications that sit
on-premises or in public cloud.
Application is an application
is an application.
The security requirements
are the same.
We have to be paying
much importance
to what our posture looks
like, regardless whether it's
in public or private cloud.
It gave us an opportunity to
look at our existing landscape
and improve our
security postures.
Along with that, there
was tremendous amount
of effort invested by
my security architect,
by security organization,
to invest effort
into a secret
management approach.
Working through our
cloud native solutions
of offerings that are
available to apply our bring
your own key strategy,
extending our perimeter,
and also just
provide segmentation
into our environment.
That effort resulted
in a very key milestone
that we achieved, where
secret applications based
on data classification
are not just welcome.
They're actually
preferred in public cloud.
That is a tremendous
achievement from my team,
and the support from
the whole organization.
So that covers the
security aspect of it.
What I'd like to go next
is the enterprise agility.
Going back to reducing friction.
So just sheer mass
scale of Schlumberger
and the amount of resources that
were migrated into the cloud.
It is incredibly
important to pay attention
to how we deployed
our resources.
How did we organize them?
How did we tag them?
Label them?
It has a significant
impact on what
happens to our
billing, what happens
to our consistency
in deployment.
And it adds organized
chaos, let's just say.
Because we were learning
as we were doing things.
And it has helped
us to learn where
we need to stop, think,
stop the bleeding,
and then keep moving forward.
So what we have done is we
have implemented consistency.
And we have tried our best,
and it's a work in progress,
to introduce automation in
that consistency effort.
My architect and
my team is still
continuously evolving along with
the cloud service providers.
There were a few
services that were just
made GA last year that we ended
up using for that purpose.
And it has been
incredibly helpful.
Next step, cloud transformation.
I think when we talk
about our focused areas,
we cannot ignore cloud
transformation aspect.
IaaS VMs is step one.
At this point, if we do not
explore cloud native services,
PaaS services that
are available already,
it is an opportunity lost.
So one of the things
that my team has
invest that effort, with support
from application teams, is
do an assessment for our
application landscape
from the perspective
of modernization.
What does it take to improve
the application stance,
and actually deploy it
in a PaaS environment?
PaaS offerings that actually
add value to our business.
So those are the ones
that we focused on.
And we worked with our
cloud service providers
to meet the gaps, to say,
let's go back to engineering.
Let's ask their hope.
And help them
challenge us to say,
where do we need to
change our standards,
and where do we need
to go ahead and maybe
work with them to introduce
new features into the services.
That has also tied back
into our security landscape.
Because perimeter has
changed in the cloud.
It is no longer just a
firewall-based perimeter.
So we had to rethink our
approach from API management
perspective, and what
PaaS environments
and what controls
do we have to apply.
So it is an accepted service
offering that we can offer.
That being said,
one of the things
that we have
tremendously focused on
is the automation aspect.
Yes.
You think about how you
deploy these services, what
controls to apply, everyone
jumps to compliance.
One of the things that we are
focusing on is consistency.
If we get to a state of
consistent resource deployment,
it will be less of a battle
to get towards compliance.
And not that we're not
working towards it.
We're working with our
cloud service providers
to find better ways to
meet that compliance.
But we have invested tremendous
effort in a few things.
Infrastructure as code.
So templating out
what we are deploying.
And with the support
of our operations team,
implementation of configuration
management system.
So every resource
that goes out there
is out there in an efficient,
optimized, and consistent way.
That has helped us tremendously.
And I think it will
introduce tremendous amount
of optimization into
the way we work.
And the buy in from operations
and the organization
has helped a lot.
There was a lot of
effort investing
in understanding what tools to
use, what approach to go for.
It has been, I think, one of
the most revolutionary changes.
And upscaling our folks
to learn infrastructure
as code and the technical
skill that applies to it.
That leads into our
service operations piece.
Yes, automation is good.
But you have no idea what to
automate until you actually
manually try out the process.
So one thing that we did is, we
had a consistent cloud hosting
process.
So the work that our operations
team, the delivery team,
was doing, is now exposed to
the rest of the organization
to utilize the services
that the team has to offer.
And it is a simplified
approach, so you
don't have a lot of feels,
a lot of questions to answer
to get resources in cloud.
That is also a work in progress,
as people start learning.
And it is a massive organization
to distribute that information
that this service is
actually available.
My team has done
a tremendous job
in presenting these offerings,
and services, and the way
that we are implementing
this process,
and getting the feedback,
and iterating it
over and over again.
We apply our learnings
as soon as we can.
And we would try to
change as much as we can
as fast as we can.
And these little
building blocks has
helped us put the pieces
and foundation together.
So for our service offerings,
we can automate these pieces.
So that is also a work
in progress for us.
That when we see
our final vision
that Abuzar will talk next
about, for our service
management and automation
pieces, that how
these efforts are
lining up for a bigger
vision for our organization.
And lastly, community
of practice.
It's very close to my heart.
And this is what ties
into change management.
Our learnings, our
trainings, our sessions,
our reference architectures
from our PoCs,
for our PaaS environments
and modernizations,
working with our cloud
service providers
partners, TAMs, learning from
them, getting that information,
getting that training scheduled,
and being proactive about it.
And getting that knowledge
to our teams so it encourages
cloud adoption.
When they take their first
step, they're not scared.
They don't know,
where do I go next.
How do I get my Google project?
How do I go ahead and
start these services?
Do we have direction?
Can I go through my
qualification processes
as I go ahead and
embark on this journey?
The idea is to spread that
knowledge as much as we can.
So these pieces, with
our guiding principles
of cloud first,
with the direction
to reduce friction, with the
direction to say, yes, we
will select cloud
native offerings.
We have a bias towards it
because we have chose that way.
And we have partnered with
our cloud service providers
to help reduce friction
in these areas.
That is where our efforts,
every work stream, every task,
every discussion, that
is how we make decisions.
For each organization
that goes on this journey,
your implementation is
going to be different.
Because your landscape
is different.
Ours has changed significantly.
Our learning, the
way we go around,
and it's a massive organization.
We figure new things
out every day.
But I hope this
actually provides
information and insight.
And if it seems like
a daunting task,
because it is a daunting task.
That being said, I'd like
to call Abuzar back up
on stage for our service
automation management
and automation pace.
ABUZAR MANAGER: Great.
Thank you, Sadia.
Thank you very much for that.
So guys, basically,
this piece of work
is our way of sharing,
for those of you who
are going to embark
on this journey,
or those of you who are
already on this journey,
to know that some of the pain
points that you feel that you
see are some of the
pain points that most
large organizations will invest
time and effort in learning
and actually building.
What I would like to talk a
bit about in the next slide
is service management
and automation.
As a part of our journey, one
of the things that happened
is that we chose to bring
managed services in-house.
Now, for those of you who have
managed services in-house,
you probably know that this
itself is a very large beast
to deal with.
Now, when we talk about service
management and automation,
we are talking about
building the blocks that
will help ensure
that we can support
the operations of
our applications
once they are residing
in public cloud.
And we are trying to
bring those applications,
and we are trying
to also align this
with our core petals of our
savings and optimizations,
our ability to provide
our agility, simplicity,
and the enablement of
technology, solutions,
and services.
So I will break this
up into two core areas.
For those of you who are
already on this journey,
you probably will be able
to associate with us.
One of the major areas is for
us to be able to build a service
catalog.
Basically, a understanding of
what our IT services are going
to be, what are our core
services that we need
to manage, because of our
applications primarily residing
in the infrastructure
as a service,
and then subsequently moving
into PaaS and other SAS
offerings of the
public cloud, it
was important for us to
focus on what we have
and what we need to support
in infrastructure as a service
today.
So as a result, the need
for a service catalog
became imperative.
It was important
for us to know what
is it that we are going to
support, but not only what
are we going to support for our
internal customers, but also
how are we going to support and
measure this against the SLAs.
So the journey was to
build a catalog that
will allow us to understand
that, promote that, and be
able to advocate our services
to our wider organization.
At the same time, build the
knowledge and the know how
of how those services
are going to be supported
with the growing
technology and the changing
technology with our public
cloud service providers.
One of those things
that I have learned
over the last 2 and 1/2 years
is that, it's like a six week
sprint, if not lesser.
Where, by the time
you have a problem,
there is an solution,
most likely, in alpha.
So you have to be ready.
You have to be prepared.
You have to be adopting
and adapting these
to be able to provide
these as a service
to your larger organization.
With the service management,
one of the core things
that we have now is a dynamic
and a growing service catalog
that allows us to be able
to support applications
across the fleet in terms
of what services can
we offer with our backup and
restoration, and some of that
we will talk about in our
operations discussion.
And then, as we
journeyed along, one
of the bigger
objectives we had was
to be able to achieve savings.
And savings in the sense,
tangible dollar value savings,
that we can show
to our leadership
as a part of moving
from our legacy data
centers into public cloud.
One of those things
that you will
see in one of the other
slides that are to come
is that, it is heavily
perceived that when
you move to public cloud, that
you start saving instantly.
Now, one of those
things that you will--
for those of you
who've already been
there will know that, savings is
something that you can achieve.
You will achieve.
But it requires a
level of education.
It requires a
level of commitment
in terms of optimizing,
and more importantly,
automating your services to be
able to achieve those savings
and actually realize them.
Because your usage in
cloud, in public cloud,
is so dynamic that
if you're not aware,
if you're not cognizant
of this very quickly,
you will start burning
holes into your savings.
So with service management and
putting a catalog together,
it was important for us to
start looking at how do we
automate some of those services
to be able to truly convert
what we were seeing into
tangible dollar values.
So, you know, automation
is quite widely spoken
and abused terminology.
When we talk about automation,
what we are talking about is
some simple ways of how we can
convert today that we cannot do
in our legacy data centers,
and is readily available
in our public cloud, to
true dollar value savings.
So an example that I would
like to share with you
is our ability to measure our
billings over a three month
cycle, and then optimize what
our configurations need to be.
And this is really
basic and simple.
So today, if you have an
application that has a month
end, or quarter end, or
a year end requirement,
in your legacy data
centers, what you will see
is that those
applications are actually
built, configured, and
specced to meet those once
off deliverables.
What you can do in cloud is,
you can actually program.
You can automate this
in a very simple way
to ramp it up at
month end and ramp it
down again after month end.
To be able to pay
those high compute,
high storage costs only when
you are actually using them,
and not for the entire
period that the application
is running.
So this was one of those
areas, simple areas where we've
been able to do automate
our presence in public cloud
and be able to save on the
compute and the operations
cost of those applications.
This is a journey that
is going to continue.
There is a lot more
that we can and we
will continue in
the automation space
to be able to achieve our
financial savings of being
in the public cloud.
But more importantly, it
is also about how do we
optimize the presence
of those applications.
One of the other
examples that we have
is that there are applications
that we run that have
different environments.
And most organizations
will be familiar with this
that, for a good set
of your applications,
you would have your dev test and
your production environments.
What public cloud
will allow you to do
is, you can automate
the shutdowns
of your non-production
environments,
and be able to optimize
on the cost savings there
by not having to pay for those
when you're not using them.
So these are some of the
learnings that we've had,
some of the stuff that
we've sort of gone through.
And we've journeyed
along and we realized
that this is where
the true rubber hits
the road when it comes to your
savings and optimizations.
At the same time,
with automation,
it gives us the ability
to provide agility
if there is a concept, an idea,
that requires an infrastructure
to be able to test, to
be able to evaluate.
The ability to do
that in public cloud
has been a lot greater than
it has been in the legacy data
centers.
For anyone who's who sort of
had outsourced data centers,
you probably know
that getting a VM
can take anywhere
between two to six weeks.
That is, if you have the right
processes and right automation
tools within your cloud
management system.
You would be able to do that
in days, if not in hours.
So what this, basically--
the focus for the service
management and automation
pillar, which was
a dedicated pillar,
wants to be able to build that
catalog and, at the same time,
convert all of those services as
microservices that can then be
tackled and then be automated.
The question should
be, what do we
do when you are in a
multi cloud environment,
and you need to be able
to not only automate,
but you also need to be able to
monitor your different services
and offerings across
a variety of clouds?
This was something that
we've sort of learned.
And in hindsight,
there are things
that can be done differently.
But one of the things that we
have done is, we've gone out
and we said, we will build
a tool that will give us
the ability to absorb APIs from
our various cloud environments
and bring it into a central
portal where we can not only
have a visualization for
our application owners,
subsequently our leadership
to be able to see how
the applications
are performing, what
the compute, what the cost for
the storage, the licensing,
and the various components
of the application are.
But at the same time,
be able to then say,
look at what are our high
frequency, complex services
that we need to do to
provide to our applications,
and how can we start targeting
automation around that?
So we've achieved a
certain level of automation
that has allowed us to achieve
a certain level of dollar value
savings, which is
aligned with the journey
that we want to proceed.
And this, in 2019, is going
to be our focus areas as we
journey along the
modernization and we continue
to optimize on our automation.
One of those things, like
I said, in hindsight,
that could have been
done differently
is, look at what SAS offerings
and other tooling methods
are available in the
market out there.
And it is growing every day.
That can allow you
that flexibility.
So that is one
thing that I think
is going to be a focus area for
organizations that are either
embarking on this journey
or are already there
and are looking to see how
they can optimize their managed
services.
What I would like
to do is, I would
like to sort of bring our
operations manager, Sheri
Wheatley, to come and share
with us some of her findings
and learnings that has helped
make Schlumberger's cloud
operations a better place today.
Sheri?
SHERI WHEATLEY: Thank you.
I'll change the slide.
Hello.
Thank you for joining
our session today.
I want to talk a little
bit about operations
and what we're doing when we
started in pretty much early
2018 through where
we are today, right?
So our vision was to
bring cloud ops in-house,
moving away from our providers,
so that we could make sure
that we support and stabilize
the applications that we're
migrating over to the
multi cloud providers.
And that basically aligns
with our corporate and digital
strategy.
So we started that.
We also started
evaluating tools,
automation orchestration
cloud tooling.
We knew we needed something to
help with the cloud operations
team.
And people, right?
People were very important.
We had to figure out--
we had seniors,
guys in our group.
They were very, very good.
We also wanted to bring
in cloud knowledge.
So we looked for specific
skill sets and capabilities
and made sure, too, we could
handle the capacity that
was coming our way.
When it comes to
our data centers,
we have legacy data centers,
multi, we have colos.
And we're working on assessing
where we could actually
start consolidating, and
closing down, and moving
a lot of these applications,
again, to the cloud.
So when we moved into
2019, we actually
started implementing the
tooling that we did the POC on.
That orchestration
automation, hopefully it's
going to gain efficiencies.
And the plan is to
reduce cost as well.
And to optimize on the capacity
and the size of, you know,
the VMs.
We also line our catalog.
So we ensure that we're going
to work through our SOAs
to meet our customer
requirements and the business.
And at that time, too, we're
also reorganizing cloud ops
to actually join the
applications team, so
that Google has been
spending quite a lot of time
with us, so that we could
adopt the SRE model and DevOps.
So that's what we're
working through, which
we're very excited to do that.
More and more of the
high valued applications,
we're moving into the cloud.
So we are also setting
up the follow-the-sun.
We've got critical
applications that
need to be supported
around the clock.
Tech debt obsolescence.
That's a big project this year.
I think a lot of people
are going through that.
And so we're working
on that, figuring
out what can we modernize.
What do we need to do?
Can we decommission?
And yesterday, really
exciting news from
Google that we can consider
using the Anthos tooling.
So we're looking into that.
And then one other area that
we need to really work on,
this is something that
we've been struggling,
and I think we finally
have a solution,
and that's our
monitoring, right?
We can't do well in the cloud
without a good application
that we can monitor on alerts.
And then last, we're
going to continue.
It's a journey, right?
Another 12, 18 months,
but we're going
to continue working on reducing
our internal data centers
on-prem.
So next, I want to
talk a little bit
about where we feel we are
today with cloud readiness.
There's five core areas.
First two, the patching
and the backup, right?
Those two solutions had to be in
place before we could roll out
anything into the cloud.
The good news is, we were
able to leverage and extend
our patching and our
backup tooling from on-prem
to the cloud.
So that worked out well.
Provisioning,
we're almost there.
But again, until we start using
that cloud automation tooling,
we're still running some
scripts and deploying VMs.
So we want to be able to bring
those quicker to the market.
And then we're looking
to working through
on disaster recovery.
It's more of Schlumberger.
I mean, DR. It's there,
right in the cloud.
But we spent a
great deal of time.
You know, security requirements,
working with the teams.
We had to deal with
the data residency.
We had to deal
with the sensitive
and the confidential data.
So that's kind of slowed
is down, but we're there.
We're now able to deploy
those systems in the clouds.
So our architecture team--
Sadia, the lead, she'll
be working on bringing
us a solution later this year.
And last, I want to talk a
little bit about security.
I think everybody knows
it's always a challenge.
You know, every
time we turn around,
there's new vulnerabilities.
You know, how do
we capture these?
How do we patch
these quick enough?
So we've partnered with
our security teams.
And they're working with us
to bring us some tooling,
simplify some of the process,
deliver reporting, as well
as dashboards.
We need that visibility.
And it's important
not just for the team,
but for the
management in general.
So that's where we're at.
And I'll turn it
back over to Abuzar.
ABUZAR MANAGER: Great.
Thank you, Sheri.
SADIA MUKHTAR: You're welcome.
ABUZAR MANAGER: So guys,
again, just recapping on this.
For those organizations that
have operations in-house,
it is one of those
areas where, I
think I can say this as
candidly as possible,
it is the most
thankless area to be in.
It is an area where you
have to keep the lights on
and you have to continue to
keep doing more with less.
What Sheri has shared with us
is that, along the journey,
since 2017 as we started to
move the first application
and had to start supporting it,
there was a barrage of things
that we had to take
on board, and we
had to make sure that we
were not only equipped
in terms of our capabilities,
but also from our capacity
point of view, to
be able to support
some of those things
that were previously
being done by an outside or an
outsourced service provider.
What you see in
the quadrant where
we are talking about
our cloud readiness,
one of the things that I
think we want to elaborate on
is that, this is our--
unlike any other organization.
Sometimes, you are the
victim of your own processes.
And we have been through that
journey, especially when it
comes around data
residency, when
it comes around security,
when it comes around areas
where you can actually--
where you're dealing
with the client data,
it puts some limitations around
what you can and cannot do.
What you see over there
is what that journey
has been in 2017 onwards.
For Schlumberger to grow its
readiness in those five core
areas, in terms of being
able to adopt and adapt what
the offerings have been
from the native cloud.
At the same time,
there are areas
where we had to go and build
certain solutions because
of the lack of those solutions
meeting our own requirements,
especially in the backup and the
restoration space, where we had
very specific application
requirements that
had to be catered to.
So it's been a journey.
And this is important
to call out,
because the growth
that you see today,
the ability that we have, and
the presence that we have today
for an organization like
as large as Schlumberger
with as archaic
applications, and processes,
and technology
debt that we have,
to be able to comfortably
stand up and say, yes.
We have a very strong footing
today in a multi cloud
environment to the position
where we can actually
stand and share our learnings
with you has required
us to work very closely
with our partners,
with our multi cloud service
partners, our application
development partners,
to make sure
that this is a robust
footing for our future state,
our modernization,
and the journey
that we want to carry
on where we can start
to PaaS our applications, and
then subsequently containerize
them.
This slide is a
slide that I think
anyone who has ever worked
with a large organization,
no matter what project you
are on, can associate with.
So what-- and I'm not going to
go through every one of these.
But one of the challenges
that, if you are already
on the journey, or if you
are starting this journey,
or if you're thinking about
starting this journey,
and there are certain
areas which are daunting,
food for thought is that
there are certain competing
priorities that you would
always have to deal with.
And we were no different.
There were multiple
large programs
that were running in
parallel that were
sucking most of our resources.
As a result of which,
capability of being
able to do this in a quicker,
in a more effective manner,
was compromised.
There is a perception
that cloud is cheap.
But like I said before,
it comes at a cost.
It comes at an awareness
and a learning.
And we need to be
mindful of that.
Security is, again,
one of those areas
that every organization will
have some challenges around.
Knowledge and bandwidth.
Again, as you journey into
cloud and the rate at which
our public and private
cloud is growing,
you will realize that this
is a constant learning.
And as Sadia pointed out, the
areas where we are focusing in
is making sure that as we grow
the skills with our teams,
we grow the skills
through proper training,
and partnering with our
cloud service providers.
License validation and budget.
Yes, there's always a
constraint of budget.
I don't think there's anyone
in the room who will deny that.
You know, money is
abundance and that you could
go out and do what you want to.
So there's always a need for
us to be able to play smart
in that space.
And it's going to be
one of the challenges
that we have to deal with.
And I think this
sort of basically
brings us to the
slide where, it's
a lighter way of
putting together
what our journey has looked like
since we started the journey.
It was the perception that the
leadership team mostly have is
that, moving to cloud is
snap of a finger, right?
You pick your applications.
You move them.
But when you go
through the journey,
there's a lot of learning.
So this slide basically
helps me summarize the blurb
that we've just been going on
for the last 42 minutes now.
In a nutshell, it does
require a significant amount
of preplanning so that your
efforts during your migration,
your failures during the
journey of actually moving
the applications, are
significantly reduced.
So the area where
I think everyone
who's embarking on this
journey should focus on
is a detailed assessment.
It's imperative that you know
what you're dealing with.
It's imperative
that you know what
is the workload that you're
carrying with you, what
is the debt that you're
carrying with you,
so that you can make
a fair assessment.
It's important to understand
that cloud first is a strategy
that most organizations have.
Gartner promotes that as well.
But at the same time, cloud, if
right, should not be overseen.
What I mean by that is that
you, as an organization,
would know what is the
lifespan of your applications.
What is the future state
of your applications.
And that, through your
assessment process,
will help you qualify
whether the application is
ready for public
cloud, and whether you
want to make the amount
of investment that
would be required in some
cases to actually cut across
the line on that side.
The other thing that we learned
as a part of the journey
is that it is important to
go down a proof of concept
to be able to
validate two things.
One, how simple,
complex, or super complex
your applications are.
And secondly, what is
the right methodology
for your migrations?
Is it a lift and shift?
Or is it a rebuild?
Greenfield?
Or is it a combination?
What is it?
Because this will help
you with two main things.
One, you'll be able to plan
and have a roadmap based
on your capacity constraints,
with your competing priorities,
your budgeting constraints,
your licensing constraint,
et cetera, on what that
roadmap is going to look like.
But at the same
time, it will help
you partner in with the
right integration partners.
So one of those
things that we learned
as a journey is that
we did not have all the
know of the tools,
of the people,
and we needed to partner
in with the right people
to help us make that journey.
As you journey
through that, you--
in 2017, once we had completed
a thorough proof of concept,
we'd done our assessment, we'd
done a good set of applications
that gave us a level
of comfort, 2017
was more on taking a substantial
amount of our landscape
and actually
running that through
to be able to validate that
our core vision around savings
and optimizations,
agility, simplicity,
and enablement of
technology, was actually
going to be achieved.
So this was just us
re-validating that that was all
still deliverable.
And 2018 was then, you roll.
So that is when we
were very focused.
We had we had our
objectives aligned
across the organization,
and the focus
was on killing our data
center and moving into cloud.
And 2018 and 2019 was
about building our roadmap
for what the future
is going to look like.
How are we going to focus
on our modernization,
and how are we going to take
the journey into now exploiting
what the cloud has to offer.
So basically, on a light
note, this is where we are.
I would like to share a
picture of the team that
has been the backbone.
Not everyone is over here.
But this is the team that
has helped significantly
work with us.
On this slide, I also want
to take the opportunity today
to stand here.
We wouldn't be
standing here and I
wouldn't have had
the opportunity
to be here if it was, A,
not because of the team that
is right behind me,
literally at the moment,
to support this journey.
But also, I want to
thank our partners.
And I would like to name a
few of them who've been very
pivotal in the journey with us.
To start off at
Google, who's partnered
with us throughout the journey.
And their engineering has
helped us support and build
for our present and
our future state.
We work very closely with our
cloud providers in Microsoft.
We've worked with Capgemini,
KPMG, Atos, Hitachi,
to name a few.
And without this support,
without their support,
without their partnering, and
as I said at the start of it,
this is the wealth
that we've built.
These are the our resources.
These are the people
who've actually
brought the skills, the
team, the tools, and more
importantly, the attitude.
The can do attitude to
make this a success.
So I want to thank
the people who've
been a part of this journey.
I know that we've sort of
shared a lot of the stuff
that you've probably
heard before.
But if there's anything that we
can share or leave with people
who are embarking
on this journey,
we'll be more than
happy to do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]